- Hardest thing is to guest on a show.
- Yeah.
- That's, it's really hard.
- 'Cause mess it up.
- I try to relax the new actors 'cause
- Yeah,
- That's really hard
to come on a show-
- To walk in
Everybody's up to speed.
It's like when I did "Friends," it was,
- Yeah
- They were up to speed.
They read, the script
- You were amazing
in "Friends."
(crowd cheering)
Did you like doing the sitcom thing?
- I wasn't amazing at what
they call the table read
- You were who cares?
Bad rehearsal, good show.
Like, no, that was so good.
That's like literally the thing
I feel like people comment
about all the time was
when Monica's on your
voicemail, breathing.
- Yeah.
- And like you were just so great.
Did you like doing the sitcom?
- I was scared to death.
I had done "Taxi" a long time before-
- Yeah.
- But I hadn't done a sitcom
and so I was really nervous
and Courtney helped a lot.
Courtney's a big help.
But that group is just
an incredible group of friends.
- Yeah, it was good chemistry.
- They obviously became friends in life.
- Yeah.
- While was on the show and I cherish
- Yeah
- And it was a wonderful place to work
and we ended up doing about nine of them.
- I know, I watched all of them.
- I was speechless
- I know,
I watched all of them
- I was only supposed to do three.
- I know, well, that's how good you are.
(both laughing)
So yeah, I was like, people love you.
I don't know if you know this.